I don't pursue the science women could
find it see how women can if it's like
notebook and it's raining in your kind
you can't tell like where the tears in
the rain are like yeah that's I think
it's cute I wouldn't say like him
sobbing over there is gonna like turn me
on but I think crying askew
okay like it's their emotional as Drake
said I gotta get this right when love
dreams sweat pants hair tie chillin with
the big bun sexy love drink if I walk
into a hole
there's that at the checkout that's sexy
yeah okay yeah Joey one liners today
girls who text first after the first
date girls sing like hi I try Nora's
first but if that inbox slides in the
text before I get one yeah yeah muscle
gold nurture Bucky headed in like Alex
mentioned about guys who spend good
night so cute guys and sing tonight text
I mean I'm gonna sign a lie so it's sexy
[Laughter]
I've been inspired and when in people
who create words like sexy or not sexy
[Music]
where are the key knee pics or shirtless
I would go with it to be honest
shirtless self seat selfie or a bikini
bikini for his way sexier a shirtless
all right I mean like I'm not gonna want
the key one major like the face of
beauty so wait what are you saying when
they're hot what are you saying so you
like the bikini medic no no I don't know
pictures of shirtless dudes like no I'm
sure it was women
[Applause]
I don't like any I mean listen I want a
little [ __ ] right let me break this
down for you what she's asking you is if
you're across the table to Kendall and
she's eating ribs polymers
oh but I'm getting a lot of text I like
to just call yeah I know I know I'm
being weird I'm in fact final one
sliding into yet I'm not a slider
I don't think it's what I'm saying is I
don't find it like I don't I don't find
that like oh my god it's so creepy yeah
it's I don't think we you know it's not
creepy but it's not sexy
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]